conservation has done 40 years of save
the pandas save the rhinos if they go
extinct everything's going to hell and
it's been a lot of doom and gloom with
nowt a lot of emphasis on here's a
problem how do we solve it
Ben Novack leads a research team devoted
to reviving the passenger pigeon a bird
that went extinct more than a hundred
years ago it's part of a broader project
created by the long now foundation a
non-profit dedicated to promoting long
term thinking the long now wants to
bring back other species too and even
has a woolly mammoth project in the
works they call the process D extinction
we sat down in the UC Santa Cruz
laboratory where Novak and his team
recover store and sequence DNA in hopes
of D extinct defying the passenger
pigeon in a nutshell the passenger
pigeon project is about trying to use
DNA from extinct passenger pigeons to
recreate as close of an organism to the
passenger pigeon as we can get contrary
to the silver screen and public belief
at times you cannot actually get DNA
from bugs trapped in amber people have
been unable to get DNA from dinosaur
fossils there's too old but you can get
ample amounts of great DNA from museum
specimens taxidermied Birds if we
continue to get the public support we
need then our projected goal is to have
some form of of passenger pigeon by 2022
most people when they think about
pigeons they think of the street pigeon
the rock pigeon the the rat with wings
they don't like them they think of them
eating french fries behind McDonald's
dumpsters and that's that's not the
passenger pigeon at all it's this really
beautiful kind of regal bird slate blue
back the male's have this red breast and
what set them apart from all the other
species of pigeons in the world
live on every other continent an island
where's that they formed these really
dense flocks and their population
numbered up to the billions so these
flocks would be several hundred million
birds to a billion birds in size and
darken the sky for several days this
species was kind of a super species for
a very long time tens of thousands of
years but what's the point of bringing
back a bird that clearly couldn't cut it
in the modern world Novak says these
massive flocks created important
disturbance cycles clearing out entire
tracts of forest with their feeding
habits and allowing for new growth and
an enriched ecosystem it's kind of like
how the Forest Service purposely starts
fires except with dense billion bird
mega flocks
so the bird we create will be you know
hopefully a bird that looks like a
passenger pigeon acts like a passenger
pigeon could fool anybody into believing
that's the original passenger pigeon you
know but at the genetic level
it's a band-tailed pigeon that's been
adapted into being a passenger pigeon so
it is somewhat of an odd sort of hybrid
there are natural analogues for this
kind of thing such as grizzly bears all
over North America
carry little bits of polar bear DNA from
hybridization that happened 10,000
20,000 years ago and over time most of
that polar bear DNA has been bred out
but a few of those genes have stuck
around we're trying to actually look at
that and design and control the traits
that we want to actually survive through
this humanized selection process when it
comes time to start thinking about
releasing these birds to the wild we
have a big challenge for us in the fact
that passenger pigeons are uniquely
nomadic they don't migrate from one set
place to another historically when you
look at the records they go wherever the
food is plentiful and the weather looks
good at that time I came out with the
provocative idea of taking white homing
pigeons and dying them to look like
passenger pigeons training the homing
pigeons to go from one spot to another
and then trying to fool our baby birds
into following those homing pigeons from
one spot to another we control their
chromosomes it's really not that
difficult life
fines away everyone asks about Jurassic
Park they bring it up for so many
different reasons and it really is the
cornerstone of thinking about this topic
it was a huge cultural phenomenon around
the world and now with Jurassic world in
theaters setting the world record for
for sales on the opening weekend which I
was part of I went in sod of course the
one thing I would say to everyone about
this is one we've been thinking about
the major issues of de-extinction far
more in depth than any of the writers of
a book or a movie could go into if we do
this right there will undoubtedly be
unknowns if you put a species into an
ecosystem it hasn't been there in a
hundred years or ten thousand years what
do you do about things that might go
wrong that you didn't think we're going
to happen specifically for passenger
pigeons people worry they think all
flocks of billions that'll be horrible
it'll be it'll be disastrous it's going
to become a monster we even got an email
of someone telling us to pull out now
before our monster pigeon destroys the
world and I have to iterate this people
caused the extinction of the passenger
pigeon in the 1800s with muzzleloading
shotguns they managed to [ __ ] a
species of five billion in the span of
50 years and today we can watch these
animals from satellites as they go with
GPS tags it's not like these birds can
get away from us in ways that we can't
control and you know it's a pigeon
what is honestly the worst that could
happen
Novak says a much more serious critique
than the fear of monster pigeons comes
from conservationists some of whom
called de-extinction a distraction that
diverts money away from the traditional
proven conservation methods while Novak
agrees that conservation is underfunded
he rejects that kind of zero-sum
thinking and believes de-extinction
presents an opportunity to succeed where
traditional conservation hasn't the real
point of the extinction as an emerging
field you know beyond mammoths and
passenger pigeons is this notion of
revolutionising conservation the real
moral fiber of conservation for the last
40 years has been extinction is forever
so prevent it in my view that that that
extinction is forever should have never
been the foundation of motivation to
begin with because it implies that
there's a finite end to solutions really
conservation has done 40 years of save
the pandas save the Rhinos if they go
extinct everything's going to hell and
it's been a lot of doom and gloom with
not a lot of emphasis on here's a
problem how do we solve it and what
we're just trying to bring to the floor
are more solutions solutions to new
challenges that traditional forms of
conservation have proven again and again
to just be utter failures at confronting
that original foundation of conservation
was about the separation of nature and
human beings which is a very unrealistic
thing to have and I think we have to
reconcile seeing that human beings and
the ecosystems and environments we've
made are part of the gradient of the
entire biosphere
will this new creature be considered at
GMO will it be considered an exotic
species will it can be considered its
own species at all the sad thing is in
the discussions that come up about law
especially when they consider what if
this thing is called a GMO is that we're
living in kind of this weird debate and
GMO backlash time Europe Europe doesn't
like GMOs they're very against that the
United States has corporations that run
agricultural GMOs and causes a lot of
distrust in the public these groups that
are against GMOs can really hinder
progress at a laboratory site we haven't
really tasted the bite of that backlash
yet but we will undoubtedly you know
spark a few hate groups when I was 14 I
read an article about a team of
scientists that took a beam of light and
stopped it in a vacuum took a beam of
energy and stopped it in one space and
time and then let it go and you know
that just really resounded in me that
human beings really can do anything if
they really push and figure it out and
apply themselves that's what this is
about if we can't get our pigeons by
2022 we'll know for damn sure know how
to get them by say 2025 that's the real
goal here is producing a body of work
that aids conservation projects with the
developments we make and continues
marching forward to doing something
revolutionary
you